Kevin you get my first question because
this happens in episode one where Travis
has his panic attack when you're playing
a moment like that do you have to
specify why that happens to him at that
particular moment is it specifically
because he is coming to realize that
hobby might really be dead yeah
absolutely it's coming from a place of
guilt that it was just one
responsibility and and he let it go away
because he was concerned with other
people and you know it's it's sad
because that character is going through
something where he's finally feeling
included by these uh girls like in at
the end of the season in some ways in
the worst ways
um but but included and so he gets
caught up in that and he loses his
brother in the process in many ways at
that time and he's starting to have to
maybe accept that in his head because
it's been a while her breaking moment
very very well played Stephen for you
during the big eating sequence what do
you think it is about Ben that makes him
not tempted whatsoever like what makes
him different from Travis and the girls
in that particular respect I've talked
about this a little bit I'm not sure
that in another setting he would have
been that different but I think in that
particular moment the way that they
approached it he wasn't even he wasn't
even looking at the the body I don't
think he was even considering that I
think he saw their faces I think he saw
their behavior and recognized like
something is happening with them that is
not happening with me and this is not
okay so it was literally just like it
was like an aversion to whatever it was
that they were going through this kind
of Trance that they had going on
um and recognizing like oh I am screwed
like Beyond screwed at this point
probably taking it a step too far I
don't even know if you have an answer to
this but they they keep saying that like
something is in them the darkness is in
them do they have a darkness in them
that has never accessed Ben yeah I mean
I'm not sure we know yet um but I think
that that's that if there there is that
thing that it's inside them I think
that's the first like inkling that I've
had that like oh something is taking
over and these These are becoming people
that I don't recognize and at this point
like my only choice is to kind of step
back and just hope that like you know I
can get by on my own without without
pissing anybody off that that just did
that to that body all right my next
spoiler question for you are not your
flashbacks but your your dream sequences
which I thought was a really nice Twist
on the Cutaway what was your very first
impression on reading that and what were
some of your biggest burning questions
for the show runners in terms of
tackling that and what it means for 1996
Ben in reality at least yeah I wanted
one of the big things was I wanted to
make sure that it wasn't going to just
be
um you know kind of uh uh
is the best way to put this is I didn't
want it to be like a generic token gay
storyline you know I think a lot of
times you have gay characters in shows
and just as a way of servicing that they
kind of throw in a storyline that just
you know kind of feeds something to the
fans and say hey we're paying attention
to this part of this character
um I wanted it to be actually something
that that shows where he came from and
and why he behaves in the way that he
does and I thought they did an
incredible job of just kind of filling
in you know his his psyche and all the
stuff that they hinted at in season one
but that we didn't actually get to see
um and you know I know you've only seen
through episode six but as as it goes
along you kind of realize that this is
even more of a descent into madness for
him you know it starts off as a real
flashback and all of a sudden now some
things from the from the real world are
seeping into it and he can't really
control it anymore
um and he and he just kind of like loses
it a little bit over the things that
he's experiencing something they're
doing so well this season it's it's true
rule but like cruel in a good way where
they're showing they're showing us what
certain characters would have wanted to
have happened but then essentially
ripping that away from them and it makes
the situation so much more heartbreaking
yeah exactly all the more sad for sure
episode six the Shauna stuff just
absolutely crushed me
um Warren for you we've already kind of
like teased this in the non-spoiler
section but Shawna does a lot of bad
things over the course of season one and
through episode six of season two really
good bad the difference is the purpose
where where does Jeff draw the line
because through it all he does seem to
always be very supportive of her and and
waiting to do whatever he needs to do
you to see you know his family through
to the other side whatever that might be
does he draw the line anywhere can
Shauna make him snap does he have a
Breaking Point how stretched how much
can we stretch
the fabric of Jeff
I think he gets pushed close to it
uh by the end of season two the the the
reconstituting of shawna's as dark
Savage Shawna uh real time
is terrifying and this is a very pretty
traditional suburbanite
Towny guy who's overwhelmed by that and
love can take you so far loyalty was a
strong bond
but
uh he may have to start thinking about
protecting his daughter and protecting
himself to some degree if he can't Stave
Off the Darkness the Beast
storyline that's excelling big time and
I love it I'll end with this one for all
three of you I kept it in the spoiler
section so you could talk about it
freely through episode six here but I
love highlighting the value of a good
scene partner so can you each name a
time when somebody in the cast was just
the scene partner you needed and helped
you access something in your own
character that maybe you wouldn't have
been able to without them mine's really
easy
um the the stuff that I that I was able
to do with Francois are not um in a lot
of the flashback stuff I it's scary
having a new actor who is completely
outside of this world come in and hoping
that it's the right match with
chemistry-wise
um and he's a brilliant actor and a
great person and we kind of we kind of
clicked like that so a lot of those
scenes just a look on his face would
kind of like send me into a whole
different world it was it was a really
great partnership through the whole
season passing director on the show
nailed it across the board yeah they're
great
easy
with expressing or seemingly effortless
how she expresses her talent and her
craft and
Juvia was very disarming and charming
and as Melanie and and as Shauna easy to
love
easy to goodness you declare Allegiance
too yeah I heard it declare Legions to
Melanie too it's okay I get it yeah yeah
but uh it was interesting because all of
last season uh Sophie Thatcher and I had
many really great scenes Sophie's such a
great person to work with and so it was
kind of a shift to have some scenes uh
with corny this year and um Courtney
just
there's something when when she's
playing Lottie that it's so calming
because it's this like reluctant leader
and and so anytime I had a scene with
Courtney would like you you if it was a
ramped up scene like it was so easy to
exactly what the character does for
Travis what happened in those scenes
with Courtney because so talented